oxford already bills itself as a
cyclist-friendly city but from next week
they will legally rule the roads
major changes to the highway code will
prioritize cyclists and pedestrians but
there's been criticism from motoring
groups after many drivers said they
didn't know the changes were coming so
do you know that the highway code is
changing next week uh no i don't know
i had no idea now now not aware of any
of the rules you know it's changing but
you don't know what the rules are
[Laughter]
do you know what a dutch reach is no i
don't actually
it doesn't sound great does it do you
know what a dutch reach technique is no
that's part of it it's a technique to
open your car door so you don't hit a
cyclist okay
no idea news to me
the aaa surveyed nearly 14 000 drivers
earlier this month and a third told them
they had no idea the highway code was
changing also four percent of drivers
said they had no intention of looking at
the new rules
whether they know or not drivers face
hefty penalties if they don't comply
including a thousand pound fine for not
using their opposite hand in a dutch
reach when they open the door janine
we're going to practice the dutch bridge
now omar teaches hundreds of people to
drive in oxford every year and thinks
cyclists should also face a test before
they use the roads
for cyclists there's no
um
there's no trainings as soon as you can
ride the bike you're on the road
everybody needs to have some sort of
test i mean like learning to drive
having to do all the theory tests and
everything it's like omar was saying
once you
can ride a bicycle you can go on the
road but you have to have
that sense of um
of what is actually happening
the changes coming in follow years of
campaigning by cycling groups of course
we all have a responsibility to look out
for each other but it's common sense
that those with the most potential to
cause harm have the greatest
responsibility the government claims
it's publicized the changes widely but
its own road safety website still
doesn't mention them
even though there's just a week to go
before everyone has to follow the new
rules of the road katie barnfield sky
news